federico sigue viviendo en la misma
habitación de cuando era adolescente
porque a los 30 años este joven sicilia
no todavía vive en la casa de sus padres
la razón es que al igual que miles de
jóvenes italianos federico no ha logrado
encontrar un trabajo estable trabajar
seguramente labora hasta emprende
terminada toda la ecuación auto para
encontrar un contrato indefinido es casi
una utopía porque lo que te ofrecen son
generalmente trabajos no declarados mal
pagados y sin contrato así que es
imposible encontrar una estabilidad
económica y mucho menos pensar en formar
una familia en un futuro de la familia
un futuro ante esta incertidumbre sobre
su futuro a federico les es imposible
dejar el nido familiar
debido al desempleo su única alternativa
es recurrir al apoyo económico de sus
padres su padre es jubilado y su madre
es maestra
[Música]
pero somos los que reemplazamos la ayuda
que el estado debería proporcionar
cuando los jóvenes no trabajan son los
padres los que tienen que intervenir así
es en italia si mi hijo necesita algo me
pongo a su disposición y mi esposa
también no podemos abandonarlo cuando ni
absolutamente el caso de federico está
lejos de ser un caso aislado en italia
más de 8 millones de jóvenes en sus 30
años viven con sus padres debido a la
falta de estabilidad financiera según
eurostat en sicilia el 51% de los
jóvenes están desempleados una de las
tasas más altas de euros y sin embargo
algunos sectores no logran encontrar
empleados
gianluca ribaudo director de esta
agencia de trabajo temporal en palermo
conoce bien esta paradójica realidad
recibimos muchas solicitudes de vacantes
en catering o para cuidar a personas
vemos que jóvenes que se quejan porque
no tienen trabajo les parecen demasiado
humildes no están listos para hacer
sacrificios somos browning
de sacrificio
[Música]
algunos consideran que estos sacrificios
son demasiado altos para obtener la
independencia la gente deja la casa de
sus padres cada vez más tarde debido a
dos cosas primero la cuestión económica
pero por otro lado está la falta de
voluntad de vivir solo significa
renunciar a la comunidad de vivir con
tus padres
se ponen un link a uno
dan carter y geoffrey hoy en día los
jóvenes no hacen nada en casa ni
siquiera saben cómo cocinar un huevo
garcía y en parte de salta nuestro las
madres nos aseguramos de que ni a la
manada en casa el problema de nuestra
cultura
programa
la cultura fic si es sociólogo durante
décadas ha estudiado los modelos
familiares italianos basados en la ayuda
mutua de italia un país que venda voto
al propio en italia es un país que ha
estado muy marcado por la cultura
católica dada la proximidad e influencia
del vaticano esto ha significado que
durante mucho tiempo en italia la
familia permaneció con su configuración
tradicional en él y mantiene el
imaginario colectivo la familia es algo
con lo que podemos contar mucho el
último baluarte de la estabilidad y
estabilidad
dentro de unos meses salvatore cumplirá
30 años
este emprendedor está al frente de una
granja que produce aceite de oliva
granos y lentejas en un terreno de 20
hectáreas
a pesar de la estabilidad financiera
salvatore no dejará la casa donde creció
con sus padres
y de víveres a enfrascar me gustaría
vivir aquí por si el pico a veces trato
de ser independiente pero siempre siento
la necesidad y el deseo de corazones de
volver aquí y comer juntos en la mesa
con sus padres ya que tiene propiedades
de alcohol y tornar a casa
a manchar en se mata a bola no es que yo
no creo que aunque lo intenta lo creo
que si se va después de unos días se
sentirá la necesidad de volver porque
sólo tiene una mamá y tu casa siempre
esto casa a casa se pre casa pero esta
situación no es común en todas las
familias recientemente un hijo de
treinta y tantos años fue desestimado
por la corte italiana le reclamaba una
pensión alimenticia a su padre para este
abogado especializado en derecho de
familia esta sentencia marca un
importante punto de inflexión cultural
en un mes otro importante que dice
incentiva anterior es una lección para
todos los hijos que quieren demandar a
sus padres acercando a través su
injusticia los jueces le hacen un
llamado a que se despierten italia
necesita hombres que asuman
responsabilidad y women y que siempre
andan en mano lares porque esta cuestión
familiar tiene un impacto en la economía
en la cultura social y en la
recuperación de este país social solar y
presa de nuestro país
según eurostat en italia de la edad
media de los hijos que dejan el hogar
familiar es superior a los 30 años esto
es 5 años más que el promedio europeo